on tv on radio and on your smartphone
this is talk tv
[Music]
right tonight on piers morgan i'm
censored with me jeremy kyle
strikes strife and sewage now an nhs
crisis looms britain does feel broken
we'll debate how to fix it a royal air
farce as the raf sidelines white men why
are our armed forces fighting culture
wars and 25 years on yet another diana
documentary investigates her tragic
death the question is it time to let the
people's princess rest in peace
there's so many coincidences so many odd
things that just don't matter 85 percent
of the ordinary people of this country
believe diana was murdered with my son
[Music]
[Music]
good evening my friends and a big big
welcome to piers morgan uncensored i am
still jeremy kyle so today we discover
train drivers teachers nurses doc
workers postal workers and now would you
believe it criminal barristers striking
apparently is the new working in
blighted blighty as a weird nation asks
if the british government can't be
bothered to work why should we
apparently by the way even the
scriptwriters have walked out here it
says insert next line and add simple
joke no at least we do know our striking
workers aren't lazy at the beach because
today apparently 22 shorelines are now
closed because of raw sewage as water
companies take gross incontinence sorry
i meant incompetence all too literally
it's a joke the government has denied
this is simply the latest attempt to
deter migrants crossing the channel
although frankly it might be more
effective now if you are brave enough to
take a dip in the dung do you get that
there's absolutely no guarantee that
anybody will be able to nurse you
through the stomach aches because nhs
bosses say our hospitals are now facing
a massive crisis too the government's
planning a campaign saying don't go to a
e if only they'd taken their own advice
apparently gps in england could even be
asked to prescribe discounts on heating
bills this winter which is all well and
good but you'd have to wait until next
summer for an appointment and as if that
wasn't enough draw breath today
economists warned that the uk inflation
rate could actually hit 19 in january i
had a joke about inflation but i'm not
going to do it because yes between the
strikes and the sewage the soaring
inflation and the wage stagnation the
lack of energy and the lack of
government it really does my friends
feel like broken britain is happening so
we're asking tonight who is going to fix
it now joining me now is dr emika
okaroka and naomi isset whose son 18
year old jamie tragically died after an
ambulance took over 17 minutes to arrive
dr amika um to start with thank you for
joining us um cheers so many people talk
about the nhs and they say it's a money
pit money gets thrown in
it's there for us but it's not there why
is it so overwhelmed and how bad is it
truthfully honestly i think it's mainly
multifactorial there's so many things
going on with the nhs that a lot of
people don't realize i think you get
like these you know sensationalist type
titles of people waiting 17 hours to be
like a doctor and whatnot but there's a
lot of context you need to take into it
so i think the nhs is obviously working
at its limit and it has been for a
number of years i think it's kind of
bubbling to the brim now where we're
seeing it manifest and patients are
coming forward and these stories are
getting more and more frequent and
that's why everyone's wondering what's
going on in the nhs obviously as a
frontline worker i'm seeing a lot of the
backlog coming in from kovid obviously
covert was a big thing that hit the nhs
we tried to adapt as well as we could
but you need to know a lot of the
elective stuff that we would have done
during covid that we had to push back
for the emergency staff a lot of that
stuff is being seen kind of now and it's
all coming to like a brim i get that and
i also get and i want to say right here
and now nurses doctors and everybody
that works in hospitals do an amazing
job and we as a nation expect them to be
there the health service but i will take
you up on one point there was an
appalling picture in the mirror the
other week of the gentleman in cornwall
who waited 17 hours for an ambulance
that his family put a tarpauling over
him they couldn't move him from outside
now if you said to that family with the
greatest of respect look this is
sensationalized headlines it's not he
waited seven years we're not criticizing
the people who are suffering what we're
saying is this is not working the nhs
front of the mail today we've got a
breakthrough for cancer
further down
you can't get through on one one one you
can't get an ambulance you can't get to
see a gp you would understand the people
of great britain are not criticizing you
and your profession but they're saying
what the hell's going on and i
understand because everyone expects the
nhs to be you know available at the
point of care which we are and everyone
expects a perfect health system in the
event in you know actuality it can't be
your colleagues are leaving in droves
exactly so one you have the issue where
you have the workforce so myself as a
local doctor i try and fill in all the
spots where there aren't doctors there
especially some of the spots where last
minute drop outs and things of that
nature and it's difficult because a lot
of the time i'm working half the time we
don't even have the capacity of staff
that we should have what would a doctor
on the front line say is needed to
combat the problem is it government is
it money is it reorganization because
that big that big argument for years is
it it has billions thrown in it why is
it not more effective without
criticizing you guys honestly it's just
not as efficient as we want it to be
it's multifactorial so it's basically a
combination of all of it i think money
obviously would help in so many
situations so social services and trying
to get people out of hospital as an
inter-social services to clear up beds
so we can admit people and ambulances
wouldn't have to wait in a e about three
hours just try and get a patient i'll
tell you on the road is picking people
up a lot of people are saying about
ambulances and i'll give you a story
very briefly to show years and years ago
about with the ambulance service and the
most shocking story was this woman it
was in birmingham she got heavily drunk
at a christmas party they had to send an
ambulance to her right she she basically
threw up in the back of the ambulance
they took her to hospital legally she
had to stay for eight hours she abused
the staff they took 45 minutes to clean
that ambulance out before they could get
out on the road right i'd fine her i'd
charge her whatever it cost to get that
ambulance out are people going to a e
for the wrong reasons is that making
difficult are they calling ambulances
for the wrong reasons because a lot of
people will say the genuine people are
missing out that's what i want to know
really the thing is you don't want to
get into that
like area of dissuading people to
actually call ambulances and call 111
and come in when they need to because we
want people to be seen if they need to
be seen and we'd always stick with we'd
rather be safe than sorry i don't want
anyone sitting there with a with a heart
with a heart attack or a silent
myocardial infarction saying oh it might
just be indigestion i don't want to
bother the nhs because that's not what
we're asking but we are asking people to
you know be sensible in situations where
they think they can actually avoid
putting themselves in risky situations
where they wouldn't have to see doctors
because let's be honest one 111 needs
upgrading doesn't it because i'm utterly
convinced and if people don't like this
sorry that it's a great great concept
but it's now manned by people who are in
a call center or just reading a tick
list because i have a an absolute story
of my own about my son and the person
that is he breathing of course he's
breathing he's crying his eyes out in
front of me i just i just it's difficult
do me a favor and i really appreciate it
let's let's cross the corner naomi issa
is a mother um whose son tragically died
of a heart attack after an ambulance
delay of more than 17 minutes naomi
thank you so much indeed uh for joining
me um
explain your story no problem
um well jamie was just turned 18 when he
actually it wasn't a heart attack he
actually suffered a cardiac arrest
during the night of new year's eve he
was at a friend's house watching
fireworks no warning at all and he sat
down on the ground said he felt funny
and they realized he wasn't breathing
and had no pulse
his friend called an ambulance called
999
and they waited and
i've heard the audio and they were
screaming on the phone where's the
ambulance why is it taking so long the
police turned up with no defibrillator
he was screaming where's the ambulance
why is it taking so long
um
the ambulance crew that turned up were
amazing the casualty doctors were
amazing the nurses were amazing
intensive care nurses were amazing but
the ambulance just did not reach him in
time and we lost jamie on the 5th of
january due to oxygen starvation to his
brain caused by his cardiac arrest
naomi first up our condolences from
everybody here
um two questions for you and and again
to the medical profession and i so
respect what you just said because they
are doing their absolute best if the
ambulance had arrived faster do you
believe that that your son would still
be alive today
yes
if if the ambulance had arrived in the
target time set out by the ambulance
service themselves of seven and a half
minutes jamie would have had a 56 more
chance of survival even at 10 minutes he
still had a chance of survival at 17 and
a half minutes that poor ambulance crew
on the way to our boy knew they weren't
going to save his life they knew it was
too late who do you blame for this i
think it's very easy to to look at the
medical profession look at the
government is a combination of
everything because to me the reason we
wanted to speak to you and the doctor
this morning this evening is is actually
britain does seem broken we don't seem
to be able to get an ambulance we don't
seem to be able to see a gp and stories
like yours really resonate what who do
you blame
well this is the problem the blame seems
to be moved from one person to the next
you know we were told by the ambulances
that they can't offload patients there
was 32 ambulances in the area where
jamie collapsed on new year's eve 17 of
them were queueing outside a e
department the a e department say they
can't get people onto wards the wards
say they can't get people out into
social care so the blame just moves
around but somebody has to sit up and
take notice he was an 18 year old boy
and he needed help and he waited and
waited until no help was was ever going
to be enough and
i
you know we keep going back to is it
money do we need more ambulance crews do
we need more doctors and nurses but i
think it's across the board that
you know we we've never blamed an
ambulance crew we've never blamed a
doctor or a nurse and we never would
they
all of the people that treated jamie
were the most amazing angels to us but
they just couldn't reach him in time and
you know we feel just as sorry for them
as we do for ourselves as a family
because they can't do any more than
they're doing but somebody's got to step
in money has to be put into our nhs to
make these services more available and
emergency health care in our town of
rugby that ambulance had to travel 15
miles to reach our boy that's how long
he waited why are there not ambulances
nearby why are there not more healthcare
provisions nearby to help him when he
needed them
naomi thank you for just a sec i'd like
to bring in ed burkett who's the head of
energy at the onward think tank for a
reason
i mean we're talking to america that
we're talking about to a person who lost
a son and the and the situation is that
it's going to get worse as the winter
goes on and you were telling my
researchers you think there's a 50 50
chance there could be blackouts this
winter what will that mean for the nhs
what will that mean for broken britain
ed
well i think you're absolutely right
there are going to be serious challenges
with our energy supply this winter i
think the scenario where we have large
scale blackouts across the whole of uk
is extremely unlikely um but there is a
chance a reasonable chance maybe it's 50
50 that some customers somewhere at some
point this winter will be disconnected
because the continent of europe as a
whole just does not have enough gas and
therefore does not have enough
electricity
in certain scenarios this winter and
that's a problem across the whole of
europe so it's not just broken britain
as per your show tonight this really is
a continent-wide problem the tuc
believes nationalizing the energy
companies would work what's your view on
that quickly i think the question is
what problem are you trying to solve the
energy suppliers which is what they're
talking about nationalizing are not
making big profits so you wouldn't
exactly make any money that you could
use to discount people's bills by
nationalizing energy suppliers the
profits at all with the energy producers
and that's why the government's put in
place the windfall tax absolutely
america um
pretty dire right now you heard noah my
story you were shaking your head it's
going to get worse isn't it more people
are going to be turning to the nhs if
they can't heat their homes they can't
see a doctor and this crisis is going to
get worse isn't it it is um my
condolences to naomi obviously and her
family and it's
really unfortunate what happened to her
son and as an emergency doctor we know
that what we call cerebral hypoxia are
not getting enough oxygen to the brain
and downtime when you pad a cardiac
arrest seconds matter not even just
minutes and obviously the seconds are
what make the difference and that's why
we need these ambulances available on
the road in rural areas in urban areas
everywhere is it briefly i haven't got
much time is it money is it
reorganization what is it how can what's
the final line to the people watching
this tonight how can we ensure that we
can get ill people to hospital it's all
of it i think money obviously first of
all but then you have to ask where's
this money going and what is actually
doing yeah there's no point pumping
money into the nhs and saying you've
given the nhs this money billion but
people still can't get ambulances people
still can't get social care because then
you haven't really
defeated the aim you haven't really
actually reached i'll tell you something
i've done this a while and you're the
most honest gp and doctor i've ever had
thank you very much dude ed burkett as
well from onward and also naomi that
tragic story our condolences to you and
your family right next on uncensored a
british supermarket chain faces
criticism not my friends for charging
eight quid for a tin of beans but for
selling non-vegan fruit heaven forbid
we're going to discuss that and dive
into all the days today's debates we're
going to bring jess's journals forward
because i cannot wait for this next talk
tv legend mike graham and former london
mayor ken livingston live in the studio
we're coming back in three
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back my friends now another week
another horrific story of knife crime in
the uk boxing hero tyson fury's cousin
rico burton was stabbed to death in
manchester over the weekend at the young
age of 31. the heavyweight champion is
now calling for tougher sentences for
knife offenders and i'm delighted to
tell you we're joining us live tomorrow
night to discuss that story and but
sadly that story is an increasingly
common one as violent crime and knife
attacks rise across the united kingdom
more crime is being committed fewer
crimes are being investigated it's just
another boulder on the mountain of
emergencies facing britain's next prime
minister it's also the first issue i'm
going to tackle with tonight's panel i'm
delighted to welcome talk tv legend mike
graham this should be real fun and
former mayor of london uh ken
livingstone gentlemen welcome you you're
in a bad mood because you've been
waiting an hour and a half
very long get a grip man let's start on
a serious note with knife crime uh you
say ken when i was london mayor i wanted
to lock up any young person who had a
knife i'm gonna throw this out there i
do not understand why we do not have
stronger deterrence i would genuinely
hand on heart if i found a youth with a
knife twice i will put him in prison for
five years it worked for acid attacks
why are we not stronger well i think the
the part of the problem is i mean if you
look back we had quite a lot of knife
crime it was getting worse and it's
mainly young men carrying a knife and
very often killing the woman that
they're actually living with and it's
got worse and i think the simple fact is
that i grew up in the world with
virtually
night crimes of course what it is today
but we were part community groups we had
friends now there's an awful lot of
young men are lonely not involved with
others they get angry well they they
gravitate communities what matters
absolutely but they gravitate toward
gangs don't they like this is a national
problem are we strong enough no we're
not strong enough and part of the
problem that we have now is very much
connected to the drugs business we've
got now massive drugs gap in this
country if you're growing up on a
housing estate in tottenham you know
you're not going to care that the guy
next to you is working hard and he's
looking after his family what you are
going to want is a very nice bmw that
you can buy as soon as you sign up to
work with the drug gangs and you stab
people as a matter of course because
that's what they do and that's the
problem if they solve the drug problem
you solve the knife problem the hot
potato is stop and search right somebody
said to me it's wrong and it's it can be
seen as racist but they got 5 000
weapons off the streets of london
when i became the mayor in 2000 we only
had 25 000 police i got it up to 35 but
the important thing i brought back
street patrols and that really had an
impact crime went down 25 percent if you
have a copper coming around the corner
every few minutes you're not going to
get involved in the sort of crime that
so many kids do and a big part of this
is about drugs and i go
i i was born in 94. i grew up in that
postal world where i mean the only drugs
were cigarettes you know literally now
the drug trade has become global and
it's appalling we need to crack down on
it a lot more so stop and search and
also come makes the point more police on
the streets because police are now
social workers and mental health workers
actually committing well it's typically
doing the macarena aren't they dancing
away again you've seen that video online
this is brilliant four policemen doing
the macarena and having a party i saw
that but that's the point that doesn't
resonate with people let's move on to a
subject that i'm sure i can't wait to
ask boris johnson gotta feel sorry for
him ken booted out by his own party
three years got brexit done watch his
phone got brexit i made the big
decisions rolled out the vaccine come on
i think the tory party the nmps are
already regretting getting rid of him
man
i mean they they look at boris i think
he's good at winning elections he beat
me easily i mean he beat jeremy corbyn
easily
that was the main reason they wanted him
the thing is most tour mps realized he
was pretty disastrous as prime minister
he doesn't do the job if i look back the
eight years he was mayor of london he
only initiated one project 75 of tory
members still want boris johnson rubbish
by the way ken because what he also
instituted much to my chagrin actually
was the boris bike you know we've now
got thousands and thousands of bikes on
the street because of boris johnson no
no i started that project when he
defeated me he then called them boris
spike well well they were called boris
box you would say that but i mean your
own party kicked you out you know and
you're saying that he's not good for the
tory party i mean you two last time i
saw you you were talking about joining
the greens for heaven's sake yeah but
they didn't keep me out before i lost to
boris i mean no they kicked you out for
different reasons
and you submitted well you are aren't
you no i mean literally the first woman
asked to marry me was jewish right okay
did you mention hitler to her because
you normally mentioned it i mean
hitler's the greatest evil in human
history yes he killed six million jews
my generation grew up
recognizing that crime and supporting
but no i've had 40 years of life i've
not just been accused of being
anticipated being corrupt alcoholic fine
and tax dodging homosexual back in the
days remember
everything
you know serious question uh one of the
things that i want to know about is we
part boris and we part the fact that uh
you know the the the tory mps might be
considering they go wrong what about the
alternative what do you make of kiersten
is he is he is he prime ministerial oh
god he is kierstarma will be our best
prime minister since clemmer atleast
they're better than jeremy corbyn would
have been absolutely
here
the alternative was worse but i mean the
thing about kierstarma is he only came
into parliament seven years ago before
that his career was prosecuting rapists
and murderers he's someone that does
things and gets them right he's not very
excited he didn't prosecute any of the
grooming gangs they did he didn't
prosecute those rapists and he didn't
prosecute an awful lot of people that he
should have prosecuted jimmy savile for
example he didn't do anything about and
he can't say that he was a great dpp but
then actually go oh yeah well that
wasn't my fault i wasn't in
to do things not to be a celebrity so
what's he famous for exactly what's he
done exactly because he can't even land
a glove on boris johnson one of the
prime ministers who was probably at his
lowest ebb and he couldn't win a point
against him in parliament questions well
hang on he's massively ahead of boris
johnson
a general election victory should he not
be out of sight though ken with respect
just briefly um you would think with all
those own goals of johnson and what's
happened i would have thought that the
labour party would be as far ahead as
blair would have been do you genuinely
believe that he'll be
well ahead in the polls if there's an
election anytime
labour will win every time i speak to
people like kierstarma and i speak to
the front bench they say the following
week we are coming from our worst
position ever because of jeremy corbyn
and if we even ended on equal terms that
would be a result you supported jeremy
corbyn i mean jeremy good thing i mean
i'd known jeremy for 50 years he was
really great friend and that's why i
supported him but i do have to say he
wasn't any good at the job now he's a
really nice guy when my wife met him
we're having a dinner together the
nicest man i've ever met in my life but
he was no good at running the machine
very interesting comment um tesco vegan
fruit i don't even understand what this
story is about what do you know this yes
it's something to do with really
with wax right apparently you know when
you put wax onto certain kinds of fruit
and vegetables to make them look nice
and shiny do you do that well they do it
in the shops right because they don't
when you buy lemon that looks manky they
want you to have a nice lemon that looks
all shiny and when they put some of this
wax on it turns out that it's made from
the husks of insects or something and
apparently vegans can't touch it are you
a vegan ken well i gave up red meat
about 12 years i gave up red meat salt
sugar butter fat now my heart profile is
equivalent to someone 14 years younger
how old are you i'm 77. you look good
for 77. so are you you're not vegan
right do you are you keen on vegans what
do you mean mike hasn't got anything i
still enjoy calamari
so you say clearly you still eat living
things what about the newts how the
newt's doing
i don't eat my nukes they're in the pond
yeah they still might how did you get
that my newts oh it's quite funny right
listen this is also one of my favorite
stories of the day uh it is a bit
tongue-in-cheek conservative condoms
apparently do you what do you what do we
know about this well they probably leak
a lot like the government
wow um apparently there i haven't got
any information where's my card with the
names of all the mum because apparently
there's lots of different information
about condoms complete silence in my ear
yeah there's nothing going on what it is
is that they've apparently come into the
conference season
but you know what labour party
conferences are concerned with
conferences they're all at it basically
i mean forget about the policies they
stay up all night all night parties
people wake up in the morning the walk
of shame oh there we are right in the
seafront they are
sure and stable i think that says strong
and stable have we got any others
the most honorable member we've got
that's quite funny do you have to have
voted to leave or remain does it matter
but
what's the story can you what do you
think of conservative condoms ken
i think every conservative should be
forced always to wear a condom so they
don't produce any more bloody
conservatives
there is one that says labor isn't
working but this cut this condom will do
you there's a market there i just grew
up in that postal world where we're all
told you've got to wear a condom or
you'll get some terrible disease which
is i mean
when aids came along i mean broadly the
the
surge in sales of condom then because
yummy your life was at risk overall guys
um we've had a bit of fun we've also had
the serious side to this um
just for 30 seconds when you look at
broken britain today when you look at a
person waiting 17 hours for an ambulance
when you know that you can't get a gps
appointment you can't see a dentist
forget boris bashing where do we go from
here ken because it does seem that we're
in dire straits we are i have never seen
my country in such a mess that we're in
now and that means you've got to improve
public spending get more people better
educated and make sure we get more
investment creating good new jobs our
level of investment is pathetic compared
to what you've got in europe and much of
the rest of the world mike i didn't
agree with ken i lived in the 70s as
well it was a hell of a lot worse in the
70s when they were in power and you had
leicester square running him up with
rats there was you couldn't bury your
own dead you know but everybody was on
strike right now all we've got is a
bunch of marxists pretending they want
more money uh when they're all paid 50
grand a year it's not a crisis
yes they are 43 000 pounds is the
average salary of those people striking
in felix though right they work for
unite they push boxes around they're
very well paid people like nurses should
be better paid that's completely agreed
do you think i would agree about that
nurse's name what do you ken what do you
make of labour mps on picket lines
briefly the the labour party based on
trade unions you're right i mean but
said you can't be in government i know
and i disagree with them about that i
think labour mps i grew up in a labor
party where labour mps were on picket
lines through all the strikes of the
time and you know
i mean i went looking for a picket line
to join when this started but there
weren't any in my area there you go uh
listen gentlemen what can i say you
might be polar opposites i've loved it
ken livingstone thank you very much
steve mike graham as well and coming
next on censor the raf tonight
criticized for sidelining white men
we'll discuss that next with a former
raf sergeant that's coming after the
break we're coming back don't go
anywhere
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is talk tv
thank you very much andrea friends
welcome back do not forget tomorrow
night tyson fury on that sad news that
his cousin
stabbed and died over the weekend
talking knife crime tomorrow exclusive
to this program we'll let you know more
about that but next the royal air force
is in the firing line for its politics
again tonight first it's head of
recruitment quit after refusing to
follow orders to sideline white men now
it's been accused of artificially
inflating its diversity tax stats you
try saying that to hit government
targets on female and ethnic minority
recruits so the question is does
positive discrimination have any role to
play in modernizing british defense or
should we in fact stick to fighting
because that's the whole point i'm
joined now in the studio by dr afsel
ashraf he was a senior officer in the uk
armed forces and actually interestingly
he was head of training management at
the royal air force and also a down the
line former sas sergeant chris ryan uh
welcome to you both um dr afsal i'll
start with you yours is an incredible
story because
you started by saying that you were
discriminated against and then went
really the whole circle tell us tell us
your view on this well i haven't talked
about being discriminated against i came
here to talk about the issue
that's in the news that's what i was
asked to do
but when i was asked yes i was
discriminated against i have documentary
evidence but that's not something that
bothers me
i had a fantastic career in the air
force it was just awesome
and that's why i didn't take the matter
further the point here
is
the issue
has been around for over a quarter of a
century 25 years ago i was invited to
help with recruitment of ethnic
minorities
i didn't take the job up
they're still struggling with a
recruitment of ethnic minorities
simply because uh there is no way of
retaining and developing the people we
actually do recruit a huge amount of
money a huge amount of resources some
very good people have been recruited to
help recruit and improve recruitment
and what we're seeing here is a
desperate attempt to meet figures
rather than look at the strategy
look at the policy look at what the
causes are and we've got 25 years of
data plus so so for me to
teach me uh something here because you
see you've got the raf one of our
most important facets and they want to
increase
all races all creeds or colors in but
what you're saying is is that it's
actually gone too far once you
understand the need for that you talked
about that and i completely agree with
that it's now at the point that we seem
unless i'm missing the point to be
discriminating i don't even want to say
about color right to me it's are we
missing out on the very best people for
the job and this blind sort of desire to
let's get you know 10 people here 10
people there what about the best people
that's what i worry about i think that
the best people are recruited the
selection processes ensure that the big
problem here is that this whole issue is
being politicized simply because
people
are desperate to meet their own targets
and the problem
is
that to in order to meet those targets
you need to make the career attractive
to the people you're the group that
you're you're you're you're trying to
attract before i bring chris ryan in is
there discrimination now
against white men
there is and if they will if if the
story is true then there is do you think
the story is true i don't know i mean
the contradictory story there's one
aspect of story saying that that is
what's happened and the the raf seems to
be denying that that is what happened
the point is that if it happens or even
if it's perceived to happen not only is
it illegal
it is very dangerous and in all of this
there's sort of national security
consider let's go to chris ryan former
sas uh sergeant live in plymouth chris
welcome uh to piers morgan uncensored
without him um chris what do you make of
this are we getting to a point where in
our quest to tick every single box in
the united kingdom we're missing out on
the best people and putting our well on
national security at risk fella
good evening
um yes you are but first of all i'd like
to say
the uh group captain
who resigned
should be applauded for her courage and
doing the right thing now going back to
recruitment you cannot force people to
join our armed forces
it's down to
you know the
the individual who has a desire to join
that unit
and if you're just picking people up off
the street because they fit a certain
demograph you are not going to get the
best people for the job
interestingly james heapey good friend
of mine the armed forces ministers today
reiterated that the government has asked
for this improvement in diversity to you
both though firstly afsa how do you how
do you achieve diversity
if you're favoring candidates over
ability how does that work well you it
won't work if that's what you're doing
do you think that's happening no i'm not
sure that that's what's happening you
see when i was asked to join the primary
driver wasn't a diversity driver it was
actually the fact that the air force was
struggling to recruit as indeed the
other forces were but the air force was
particularly struggling to recruit
people in the technology field where
they felt by opening up
to an untapped area of talent
they could increase the talent that they
needed so the problem
isn't
diversity for diversity sake
it is because there is a need to uh make
get the talent the best talent from all
aspects of british society i get that if
i can bring chris back in of course we
want the best talent from every part of
the united kingdom as as as as dr rafael
says but to me unless i'm missing the
point unless this report doesn't seem to
be true but there seems to be more
coming out the whole time we are now
missing out on some of the best talent
in our quest to tick boxes and
you you say about the group captain
there is a frustration how do you see it
do you do you think i'm speaking
truthfully there or do you think that
this is being built up do you think it
really is an issue
well jeremy you've got to remember we've
the our armed forces were embedded in in
two campaigns for over 20 years this you
know this career path may not be you
know what a young man or woman wants to
do now now the regiment has always
suffered or the sas has always suffered
for low numbers and they've always been
on demand and this whole thing is you
can't force anybody onto selection you
know you've got to first of all make the
package attractive you know these these
young men and women
aren't paid very well and they're
expected you know to put their lives on
the line um from that side it it comes
back down to you cannot force people
into our armed services now i served
alongside a number of guys of color
and i'm telling you now they would be
affronted if they thought they were
given something and they didn't deserve
it or they didn't work for it or they
weren't capable of that position they
held
now once you start doing this with the
figures it is absolutely wrong and it
just does not work what the government
should do is make the package more
attractive to bring young men and women
into this into this mill into our
military
um based on what you've heard uh
absolutely and i completely get what
you're saying you know one doesn't know
whether this is genuine or not we live
in a world where it seems to be about
diversity targets but on the ground um
yours is a very interesting story we
started by saying that you suffered
discrimination you were honest about
that and yet you got your head down you
carried on you said i had the most
awesome 25 years
when you look at the military today
would you join again i would
but i want to come back to what chris
has said i think he's made some very
good points one is
if the story is true uh this group
captain deserves a great deal of praise
because no matter what the issue is
people should stand up for what they
believe is right and i think this is
something that uh she deserves a great
deal of applause for the other thing
that chris has said which really
deserves to be taken on board and that
is that any person
color or whatever um
deserves to know that they've achieved
it on marriage and elite organizations
whether the royal air force or the sas
it is difficult to get in
it is extremely tough to get in i can if
this if i tell the stories the people
that didn't make it with me um you know
through uh bone fractures through
epilepsy stress-related epilepsy so many
people didn't make it and i did and i
wouldn't want to be a token and in those
days of course there was none of that
tokenism there was none of this
diversity issue
so you think that very quickly both of
you final question do you think
diversity is important absolutely do you
think the drive for it has been done in
the wrong way you both talk about how
people of color absolutely who have
served and and quite rightly would feel
affronted and i completely understand
that but do you think there is any part
of in this quest for diversity
that they've taken the wrong path and we
are missing out on people yeah
they have taken the wrong path in that
they're looking at um discrimination and
recruitment at the front end it doesn't
really exist 99 of people in the armed
forces are not um prejudice it does
exist at the very senior level because
you get a pinnacle there where there is
it's high competition i didn't
experience any uh prejudice for the
largest part of my career i noticed it
when i looked at my filed and stuff and
my performance at the top end and that
is where it gets difficult if we had uh
like we have politicians members of the
house of lords
leaders in business and elsewhere
of color or females uh in the armed
forces then we would have a problem and
25 years ago we could have grown a lot
of talent i'm not talking about myself
but there were several only very small
number of officers of color who were
extremely talented why didn't they make
it
why didn't we have air marshals
or females and of color that's the
question if they address that question
you will solve the recruitment question
after thank you very much final word
from you chris um your overall view of
this summit jeremy um
jeremy um joining the military whatever
branch it's an organic thing
and you can't cook it you can't change
selection i'll give you one example in
the late eighties a commanding officer
was under pressure to bring more men
into the sas and they tweaked selection
and made it easier and what that meant
was there was a number of guys joined
the sas who weren't capable of that
position and sadly some of them were
killed
as i've said there's a process of
joining our military and it shouldn't be
tweaked no matter who you are or where
you've come from completely agree chris
ryan a former essay sergeant in plymouth
and dr assal ashraf thank you very much
for joining us and next on uncensored my
friends a new documentary uh tonight
untangles conspiracies around princess
diana's death there are still questions
apparently to be answered after 25 years
we'll speak to the former spokesperson
for the al fired family michael porthole
along with firebog for tom bow that's
next on uncensored don't go no we're
coming right back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back to uncensored now princess
diana's tragic final hours remain the
subject to much speculation and scandal
even 25 years on from her death channel
4 is the latest to enter the fray with a
four-part documentary investigating
diana death in paris which examines two
police investigations into her passing i
think this have a look at this actually
just start like this
there's so many coincidences so many odd
things that just don't matter 85
of the ordinary people of this country
believe diana was murdered with my son
why would someone want to kill the
princess it's very difficult to defeat a
conspiracy theory
so do these anglers inquirers shed
important new light on one of the royal
family's darkest hours or is it finally
time to let the people's princess rest
in peace i'll be joined shortly by try
firebog for tom baub with me now is
royal commentator and former spokesman
for mohammed l fired michael cole
michael thank you for joining us tonight
what do you make of this new documentary
evening
i didn't watch it i chose not to watch
it uh i didn't contribute to it i
declined the invitation
um
i took those decisions because i didn't
think it would elicit anything of any
substance that was new
this morning
a very famous tv household name who was
on television even before i joined
television in nineteen sixty seven
he said to me nothing new michael
and
i did read
the comments by christopher stevens the
very distinguished
television
reviewer in the daily mail today and he
described the program as trashy
cynical documentary
with sound bites struck strung together
so maybe i made a good decision but the
reason
i found it
and find this
all very
very very sad
is that it's it's distressing
i knew
all three people who were killed that
night i i knew diana for 12 years i went
around the world with her
she occasionally phoned me she
occasionally asked advice
we weren't close friends she didn't ask
me out to lunch but we had a good
professional relationship
dodie was always in and out of my office
when he was in london and i knew henry
paul henri paul drove me around in paris
i always got on with him very well
so those were people i liked and admired
and
like mohammed who is still in mourning
after 25 years
i miss them
and
i think it is
a shame if i can put it as lightly as
possible
when this old ground is raped over
for very little purpose on four
consecutive nights on a terrestrial
channel
what is achieved you know jeremy i would
sit here and talk to you
from now until the anniversary next
wednesday
if it achieved anything if it brought
them back and of course it won't do that
so what are we doing here um i'm all in
favor of honest journalistic endeavor
yeah and i do believe that information
will will come out in time i think is
this the right way of doing it i think
if i can jump in i i agree i think i
think many people would quite rightly
say it's distasteful others would say
that maybe there are still questions i'd
like to cross now if i can to fire
biographer tom bower who joins us now
tom what's your take on this this new
program what's your view sir
well my view is simply this that the
whole controversy was actually created
by mohammed fayed and i must say
my old friend michael cole because the
whole suggestion after the death
that princess diana had been murdered by
prince philip and mi6 in some gigantic
conspiracy in paris was utterly
outrageous by a shameless man called
mohammed fayed and his acolytes and
spokesman i was amongst the very very
first not the very first person to
arrive at the ritz courtesy of mohammed
fayed shortly after diana died and i
spoke to all the hotel staff at the ritz
who had served her and dodi in the hours
before they then
bid them farewell from uh from the
richmond to their fateful deaths and i
can tell you that that dash by the car
honorary paul the drunken driver
speeding through paris was approved by
mohammed fayed the staff the ritz told
me that they heard the conversations
between dodie and his father approving
that ridiculous
escapade and the idea that anyone could
have plotted to murder diana which is
what mohammed fired perpetrated for 10
years afterwards and why we have these
programs now is absolutely outrageous
there was absolutely no way that anyone
could have plotted uh an assassination
attempt if they even had the motive
which they didn't and so
it is a tawdry affair what's awful about
the four-part series now is that
regurgitates all of mohammed fayette's
rubbish and not only rubbish but
damaging rubbish it defames so many good
people not least of all diana because he
came up with a ridiculous idea he had
her last words which was a total fantasy
so what's really shocking about this uh
series and you know it's just television
so who really cares is that it took 10
years for a proper inquest 10 years
before diana's death was subject to a
judicial inquiry which was outrageous
amount of time and when fired actually
turned up in court with his lawyer
michael mansfield they didn't have a
scintilla of evidence to present which
justified their long campaign that diana
had been the victim with dodie of an
assassination attempt charming that was
all over tom thank you
just regurgitates all that i just want
to bring michael back in not much time
michael your response to what thomas
said briefly sir please
well uh it wasn't muhammad's fault that
it was a ten year delay and there were
four uh coroners appointed until they
got to the one who they thought would
bring michael michael did mohammed
did mohammed al fired in tom's words
peddle untruths and full sets about it
and is the very reason that 25 years
later these programs absolutely made
he he's in he's entitled he's entitled
to his opinion he believes that his son
was killed and he was killed because the
establishment did not want the mother of
the future king to be marrying a muslim
and that's what he believes that he's
entitled to his belief and on the
anniversary he'll go down to dodie's
tomb and he will sit there for a couple
of hours listening to recorded prayers
from the quran and then he'll go back
and he'll have afternoon tea with his
children he is still in mourning he's a
man bereft he lost not just his son but
a very good friend and the allegations
that tom is blithely throwing around i
could answer every single one of them
but we don't have time we don't tom
bauer final word from you please briefly
and i mean very briefly sir 20 seconds
well all i can say is he's had 25 years
to prove his conspiracy and i think it
was shameless and cowardly of him to
accuse prince philip of orchestrating
the murder of diana and the rest of the
people in that car it's shocking he was
a drunken driver driving recklessly
drunk and the pr sadly princess diana
wasn't wearing tom bower michael cole
thank you very much indeed i think you
two prove i think the country in the
world is probably still split thank you
so much for watching and that's it for
me do not forget tomorrow night live on
the show tyson fuero joins me live tell
us a few are talking about his cousin
who was stabbing a lot more don't miss
it and just as pierce says wherever you
are make sure you keep it uncensored
have a great night
[Music]
i'm tommy dunn and this is talk tv the
most memorable moment in my career
without sounding completely conceited it
has to be interviewing president trump
in the open office in the white house
particularly the little red button he
had on his desk i had no idea what he
did his interview went on one of the
more rumors is going to launch a nuclear
strike on north korea or open up a shark
pit that i then fall into
turned out he pressed it right at the
end of the interview and then walked a
butler with a tray and carrying it dark
it was a diet coke
[Music]
this is talk tv news
good evening i'm emily rose adams new
forecast show that household energy
bills could top 5 300 pounds by april
the soaring costs have led to fresh
warnings inflation could hit more than
18 next year which would take it to its
highest level in nearly half a century
british airways will be cancelling more
than 600 round trips up to the end of
october as thousands and thousands more
after that it comes after tens of
thousands of summer flights were
cancelled out of heathrow due to staff
shortages the airline says flights are
set to be impacted over winter until
march next year and angry protests have
broken out outside of old trafford where
manchester united are taking on
liverpool tonight fans are calling to
oust the club's american owners the
glazer family
that's all for now we'll have more news
updates after the talk
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you